foreign
[Music]
a customer engineer for machine learning
at Google cloud and welcome back to the
technical guide for startups where we
are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to start build and
grow their businesses successfully and
sustainably on Google cloud in our
previous episode we shared with you how
to visualize your data with data studio
and looker
today we are moving on to our eighth
stop which is machine learning on Google
cloud with pre-built apis and other ml
in today's video we will be covering how
to select between the various Google
Cloud products for your ml use case
what are the different ml apis that
Google Cloud offers and how you can use
them
workflow for creating a production
custom model
and finally how to use automl to
leverage on Google Cloud's machine
learning expertise selecting the right
machine learning product this decision
tree gives you a quick overview of which
property use
let's go through this in a bit more
detail
if you do not have your own training
data and pre-built models fit your needs
ready to use ml apis are the way to go
if you do have your own training data
but you do not plan on building the
model or writing the code from scratch
automl is the right choice for you
if you do have the training data and you
do plan on writing your own code in SQL
format bigquery machine learning is your
body
and if you do have your own data and you
are planning on building your own model
in a non-sql format typically with
python and using Frameworks like
tensorflow custom model tooling of
vertex AI is the perfect choice
machine learning apis are extremely
powerful pre-packaged solutions that
help you get started on your ml Journey
right away
you can make use of Google's world-class
state-of-the-art models to accomplish
the most common ml tasks
if you need more customization for your
tasks with custom predictions and custom
data sets you can make use of automl you
can start building your own high quality
custom models by using Advanced
Techniques like learning to learn and
transfer learning from Google
Cloud automl can make AI experts even
more productive and advanced new fields
in Ai and help less skilled engineers
build powerful AI systems they only
previously dreamed off
finally for data scientists and ml
Engineers vertex AI allows you to easily
train and compare models using automl or
custom code training and all your models
are stored in one Central model
Repository
these models can now be deployed to the
same endpoints on vertex AI
it also comes with a whole host of other
features that we will be exploring in
the next video using pre-trained models
with apis let's start off with the
scenario where you do not have your own
training data in order to leverage ml
for your use case we recommend using
Google Cloud's apis for preteen models
Google Cloud currently offers six major
ml apis as part of our Cloud AI
offerings
Cloud vision
Cloud video intelligence Cloud natural
language Cloud translation
Cloud text-to-speech and Cloud speech to
text
we will now explore a couple of these
apis natural language API
let's explore a simple demo of the
natural language API on its homepage
fun fact you can actually explore all
the ml apis free of charge on their
respective home pages
I have added a standard description of
Google in the text box as input to the
API from that you can see the output as
shown in the figure
there are four main tasks that the
natural language API can do
entity analysis sentiment analysis
syntax analysis and content category
classification
natural language API has a few
interesting features
it can perform sentiment analysis it
essentially can decompose a sentence and
identify the different parts of speech
in it like a noun verb Etc
it can also do the task of sentiment
analysis for every sentence natural
language API can provide a sentiment
rating on a positive to negative
Spectrum
it can also perform entity level
sentiment analysis
it can perform content classification
into predefined topics and subject
matters
finally it is able to do entity analysis
which basically identifies and to
categorizes entities into 13 different
entity types
you can use all the ml apis the same way
through an API call or through the
Google Cloud SDK a sample request to the
natural language API to classify text
looks something like this Vision API
with vision API you can use rest and RPC
apis to automatically
classify content using predefined labels
detect objects and retrieve object
coordinates
identify products from your catalog
detect Brands and product logos
detect thesis and emotions
detect popular places and landmarks
find similar images on the web
moderate explicit content
identify image properties like dominant
colors get crop hints and finally detect
and extract printed and handwritten text
Luna Park is an amusement park in Sydney
if we send this image as input to the
vision API we can test out the various
features the first one being label
classification
some of the probable labels it outputs
are Landmark architecture and amusement
park but with different levels of
confidence similar to that it is also
able to detect emotions based on the
facial landmarks
you can get the confidence levels of
different emotions as well as part of
the API response Vision API also has the
capabilities to do OCR on the input
image
as you can see from the Luna Park image
it is able to clearly recognize the sign
board another cool feature about Vision
API is that it can perform Landmark
detection
this detects popular natural and human
main structures within an image video
intelligence API
the video intelligence API is similar
except it analyzes videos it can do
things like track objects transcribe
audio detect explicit content and more
you can still process large video
archives stored in Google Cloud Storage
as a batch process or you can use the
streaming API to annotate videos in real
time to take immediate action
capabilities for live streaming support
hls rtsp and rtmp protocols
let's now explore the other apis in the
form of a demo
I will be showing you a demo of a web
app which chains together three apis
speech to text API translate API and
text-to-speech API
this will show you how you can get near
real-time translation of a speech from
one language to another
as you can see I have this very simple
web app with a couple of different
options
I can choose my input language from a
list of different languages we support
in my case it will be English and my
target language again from a list of
different languages and in my case it
would be French
I can also choose the model that will be
used to perform the speech synthesis we
have two different options here a
standard and a wave net
a standard voice is just parametric text
to speech which generates audio by
passing outputs through signal
processing algorithms called vocoders
there is also a wavelet voice which is a
premium voice generated by the waynet
model which we use to produce speech for
Google Assistant search and other
products this is more natural sounding
than other text-to-speech systems
and finally you can select the variation
in the voice you would like let me
select option b now when I press click
to start and speak something the app
will translate my words from English to
French let me show you what that looks
like
hi my name is Abhishek
welcome to the technical guide for
startups
as you can see by training multiple apis
together we are able to perform a speech
to speech translation instantly
this can be used not just to impress
your friends but also has a lot of real
world applications in various Industries
like e-commerce retail banking legal
customer service and so on hope you
enjoyed that demo
let us now talk a bit about when you
would potentially need to use ml for a
custom task that you may be having what
about custom tasks how can Google Cloud
help you solve them now I know this is a
very simple use case but imagine there
is a scenario where you need to classify
whether an image is a cat or not
this can be accomplished by calling the
cloud Vision API and checking the
confidence scores for the label of cat
but now if you know that your input
image is a cap you now want to know what
breed of cat it is
then how can this be accomplished a
pre-built API would not be helpful in
accomplishing your task here
we would in fact need a custom cat breed
prediction model let us now see how you
can build a custom cat prediction model
in general
step one is to identify the problem
we Define the problem as to identify the
different beats of cat from an input
image
step two is to gather the pre-processing
data needed to train a custom model
in this step we either find a data set
or scrape the internet to get different
sets of breeds and create a data set
with these label breeds in step 3 we
split the entire data set into two parts
one for training the model and one for
testing it
we do not expose the testing data set to
the model during training
this removes any bias in the model
prediction and ensures that our model
generalizes well step 4 we then need to
use a machine learning framework like
tensorflow import various libraries and
build the model structure
this process gets more and more
complicated as we go on
step 5 we finally train the model and
evaluate the model against the Unseen
data in the testing data set finally if
we want to productionize the model and
expose it to the end users we need to
save the model artifacts and deploy
either as an endpoint hosted on Google
cloud or get it running locally to serve
the predictions on device step 7 is that
we can finally serve the predictions by
hitting the predict endpoint this entire
process gets super complicated at the
end so is there a way to simplify this
entire process
absolutely
that is where we have Auto ml
automl provides a UI for Gathering
training data and evaluating models
here's how it works
upload your training data depending on
which order amount variant you're using
it could be images text or translated
sentence pairs next click the train
button in automl UI to train your model
it is as simple as that
once your model is done training it will
be automatically available for
predictions on Google cloud and it
scales automatically
finally you can generate predictions you
can try it out in the UI or build an app
that queries your trade model with the
API
so how does the entire process to build
a custom CAD bead prediction model look
like now
you can see that once you gather the
data your job is pretty much done automl
handles the splitting of the data
training the model evaluating it and
deploying it into production
all that is left to do is to make the
predictions and harness the power of ml
in your application
we saw a use case for autumnal Vision
let's see what else you can do with
automl in particular automl natural
language
you can create a model that is able to
generate custom labels for example here
we are looking to classify the
description of a movie into different
movie genres
to achieve this you can download a
public data set from kaggle like the
movie lens data set and use that to
train the automl natural language model
another interesting use case you can
build using this is a custom sentiment
analysis model for example let's assume
you are an airline company and you would
like to classify how satisfied or
dissatisfied your customers are with you
can build a custom sentiment analysis
model using automl
another use case could be in terms of
entity extraction
all pre-trained entities may be a bit
generic for your use case for example
cappuccino here is recognized as a
consumer good
you can then train an automl model to
perform custom entity extraction in this
case it is able to recognize cappuccino
as a beverage automl tables
according to McKenzie Global Institute
data in its basic form structured data
is likely to drive most of ai's impact
with time series being a close second
in order to help you overcome these
challenges we decided to build automl
tables a tool for enabling your entire
team data scientists analysts and
Developers it helps to automatically
build and deploy state-of-the-art
machine learning models on structured
data
based on the benchmarks we've done the
results speak for themselves
there are a number of vendors in this
space and we chose to Benchmark against
a subset of them with similar
functionality
Benchmark on Kegel competitions which I
love as a benchmark because they involve
real data from a real company that is
putting tens to thousands of dollars of
prize money on the line to get a good
solution and willing to wait months to
get a good result and thousands of
serious data scientists around the world
compete
tables are usually in the top 25 which
is usually better than existing vendors
we tested so overall we do quite well
let's Deep dive on one of the data sets
where automl tables performs well the
mercari price suggestion challenge
mercari is Japan's biggest Community
powered shopping app and Marketplace
and they created this challenge for
predicting the price of a product
offered on their Marketplace so that
they could give price predictions to
their sellers
three months hundred thousand dollars
price two thousand data scientists
completed and there were 99 entries for
the winner
the entire data set consisted of 1.5
million rows of Rich data which had
plenty of noise now what you see here is
a curve where we laid out the
performance of each participating team
in terms of the final error rate they
achieved
on the x-axis is the team's rank on the
final leaderboard we're going more to
the right means that they did better and
on the y-axis is the error where higher
means that they did worse
as expected you see a curve down to the
right but this curve isn't even
a steep drop where every subsequent team
does significantly better than the
previous one
followed by a long Plateau where each
team does about the same almost as if
the signal from the data has already
been squeezed out of
this is how tables performs after
different hours of training
there are some caveats to this the
search process is random we did do some
limited data cleaning and of course
other data sets could have different
results
but still for a million plus row data
set with significant complexity one art
gets you to the plateau and oh by the
way compared to the hundred thousand
dollars price for this challenge one
hour of training is just 19 percent
and click one more time and the bottle
is ready for deployment
this brings me to my final Point automl
tables will save you money not only does
it increase your team's efficiency but
there is no large annual licensing fee
you just pay for what you use
this is a small margin over what the
cost of the underlying compute and
memory infrastructure use would be
so for example training costs 19 an hour
like I said earlier and this represents
the use of 92 Ford CPU machines under
the hood and prediction and model
deployments are even cheaper let's talk
about Job Cam and their ml Journey on
Google Cloud
jobcam is a SAS which uses video
technology to help recruiters to reduce
unconscious biases during hiring process
using AI
they concealed the candidate's identity
by blurring their images and changing
their voices and video interviews or
video resume
with this they help the decision maker
to evaluate candidates just for their
competency abilities and experiences
instead of their gender race ethnicity
religion Etc
they were able to reduce processing
tiles for automatic speech recognition
using speech to text API by 93 percent
from 5 minutes to 20 seconds
they also use cloud storage to reduce
the video serving latency to their end
users thereby providing them a better
experience on the platform
today jobcam is a platform connecting
various companies with more than 50 000
job candidates in Brazil alone
the process shakeup led to a hundred and
thirty percent increase in turnover in
the social distancing phase alone
coming up in the next session we will be
exploring more on the machine learning
options within Google Cloud an overview
of vertex AI automl capabilities when
vertex AI custom model building with
vertex Ai and finally a demo and a
customer case study hope this video has
been informative to you and your
business on how you can leverage the
power of Google Cloud's machine learning
apis to build and grow rapidly
[Music]